[Music]
China is the world's last remaining
Empire today China is powerful enough
expanded some periods and establish
itself as the Middle Kingdom in Asia as
it was for most of its history its
current leader Xi Jingping sees himself
as a modern-day Emperor under XI China
will try to expand its maritime and
territorial claims in the South and East
China Seas and coerced Taiwan the last
holdout to Chinese so-called
reunification it will challenge us
primacy and the american-led security
system in the indo-pacific given Chinese
increased power and prestige his
ambitions are only growing she believes
he can achieve the long-held goal of
national rejuvenation Washington needs
to establish a strategy that pushes back
on Chinese expansionism and strengthens
alliances with the Asian partners the
goal of this strategy should be to force
China to choose between expensive
Imperial expansionism
or badly needed socio-economical to
learn more about my take on Chinese
imperialism check the links to the book
rise of the revisionists in the
description below also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI